okay welcome back everyone
um let's get started so
um we are in the fifth lecture today and
today we're going to switch over to
classification and before we switch over
let's do a quick recap of
what we've covered we covered
prerequisites
and we started with supervised learning
and supervised learning is basically
learning a mapping from x to y
and we started with regression and
looked at the very first
regression algorithm linear regression
where we are trying to learn a mapping
from
some example x which lives in a d
dimensional space
to an output y which is a real value
and we assumed or we limited ourselves
to
hypotheses or you know models which
belong to this family
of the form theta transpose x where
theta is
some parameter that identifies the
specific member of our
hypothesis family and we wanted or
the desired outcome is x x theta
or here x is a design matrix and y is
the vector of all
all all outputs we want x theta to be as
close as possible to
y but in general this will never hold
true
x x theta will almost surely never be
exactly equal to y
and the the method that we
fall back to is to define a cost
function
which is the difference between x theta
and y
x theta minus y and that is going to be
a vector and you take the squared norm
of it
and the squared norm is basically
exactly equal to the sum of the squares
of the individual terms
or the sum of this errors of each
example right
and we want to minimize this sum of
squared errors
by choosing an appropriate theta right
and we saw two different kinds of
solutions for that a numerical solution
and a closed form solution
so in numerical solutions again we saw
two different methods
gradient descent and stochastic gradient
descent the key difference between the
two is with gradient reset we consider
all examples for every step so these are
iterative algorithms where at each step
we start with a random initialization of
theta and each at each step
time step we make some change to theta
updated by some amount
and in gradient descent for each update
we consider all the examples
and for stochastic gradient descent we
consider
one example at a time and the way we
perform the update is that
for the next time step the theta for the
next time step is going to be
theta of the current time step minus
alpha
which is some step size times the
gradient of the loss
and this happens to be the gradient for
the square glass
i probably forgot a half over here for
this to be the gradient
and another way of writing the same
thing is
in this notation we have different
variables for theta t and theta t plus
one
but if you are implementing this in a
computer program
you would have some variable uh for the
parameters and you keep
updating it over and over so when when
we use the notation of colon equal to it
it means you're performing an in place
update of the variable which makes more
sense if
you think about a computer algorithm
whereas this makes more sense in
as a mathematical expression so ah you
update
theta in place by the current theta
plus alpha times
the negative gradient right these two
are exactly the same
i switched uh i change the minus to a
plus and therefore
swap the order and theta transpose x is
um is basically the hypothesis
so you know this is an important
equation to kind of you know pin it in
your memory we're going to
see this pattern over and over again and
then there is the other solution which
is the closed form solution
it exists for linear regression but it
may not exist for
different kinds of models or algorithms
in which case you use gradient descent
or stochastic gradient descent
but for the linear regression alone um
you can you can um start with the cost
function
do some matrix calculus you know take
the derivative set it
equal to zero and you end up with the
normal equations which you can invert
to get the closed form update for
calculating theta this is not an
iterative algorithm
you calculate this and bam you have the
final solution you don't have to iterate
over and over whereas with
um numerical solutions you want to
iterate over this over and over until
you hit some kind of a convergence
condition which means your theta has
stopped
changing a lot or your cost has stopped
reducing
so there are there are different kinds
of convergence conditions we discussed
last
uh in the last class uh but this would
be
iterated until you hit a convergence
condition but this is just a one step
algorithm where you where you calculate
the final solutions and you're done
and we also um looked at a couple of
interpretations of
linear regression the first is if we
assume a gaussian noise
ah for each example which has
mean 0 and some constant variance
sigma square which which actually does
not matter for our calculation because
we assume it to be a constant it could
be a big variance small variance it
doesn't matter
as long as it's a constant variance for
all examples
um we are good uh
and we assume that y is uh the observed
y
is some true y you know
this is some kind of a true y plus some
noise
so right you can you can kind of think
of this as the signal
and this is the noise right and you you
you are making a noisy observation
right and the goal of um linear
regression
is to given x's and y's we do not know
what the
individual noise terms are given x and y
we want to recover
theta right we want to kind of weed out
all the noise and extract the signal
that is the
general intuition and with this
assumption we get a uh
likelihood expression uh p of y unit x
or or the density for y
um given x and theta to be this gaussian
distribution
and when we take the log likelihood we
saw that uh
even though the gaussian distribution
has all these terms
uh when you take the log kind of you
know all of these are constants
the log and the exponent cancel and this
is constant for
all examples and this is just another
constant so the log likelihood
essentially boils down to just the
squared error between between um
between the prediction and the observed
noise and we perform maximum likelihood
estimation uh we sum we've seen maximum
likelihood a couple of times
so far maximum likelihood is basically
take the
the define the likelihood across all the
examples
and because of the independence
assumption you can you know
the the joint likelihood is just going
to be the product
of this term across all examples
and then take the gradient of the log
likelihood
with respect to theta set it equal to 0
or you can solve it with
gradient descent right so the the
um and what we saw was that performing
maximum likelihood uh estimation
was exactly the same as minimizing the
squared error loss
right there is a negative term here so
maximizing the likelihood is the same as
minimizing the squared order loss if you
assume you are
noise to be gaussian
so in in general if you are defining
your
objective to be the maximum likelihood
objective
right it has a one to one correspondence
with having a loss
where the loss is equal to the negative
log likelihood i take the log likelihood
flip the sign and that is your loss
function and in this case
you take the uh likelihood take the log
flip the sign you just get the squared
error
and this holds true for any
probabilistic model
not just uh one way that assumes uh
gaussian noise it could be any
um any probabilistic model whatsoever
you define the likelihood take the log
of it flip the sign that's a loss
function
right now we saw yet another
interpretation uh
the projection interpretation where um
we want to we would we we want x theta
to be equal to y
but that is never the case ah because
y lives in a higher dimensional space
compared to theta
right and theta will map to some
some subspace in in in this y space
which is which is
uh you know which goes through the
origin which is also the column space of
x
and the observed y will almost surely
never
live exactly on the subspace because we
are adding
some noise if the noise was 0 then you
know you would expect your y to be
some linear combination of x's but
because there is some noise your y will
be
will be outside the subspace right so
instead what we want to do
is project this y onto the subspace
let us call it y hat the projected point
right and once you project it
you can actually solve x theta you know
exactly equal to y because now it is
projected onto the column space
right and the way you project it is to
take y
and multiplied by the projection matrix
right and this
this this whole term will be y hat the
projected point and now
x theta will will actually be you know
exactly equal to this
this um projected point and you know
because
you know um because they're exactly the
same you can you can
cancel x and you get theta equals x
transpose x inverse x transpose y which
is which was the
normal equation what we saw right so
that is what we covered
ah any questions before we move on to
classification
yes question
so in this case how do we know x x
matrix is invertible
for for now we will just assume x matrix
is invertible and you know we'll come up
with remedies for later in the course
when it's not so for now let's assume
x matrix is inverted
yes question
so the question is if the observations
are not independent does this does this
theory all hold um if the observations
are not independent
none of this theory holds right all this
all this theory is is making
an independent assumption you know iid
assumption right
only because of which you can you know
multiply them together take the log
decompose it into separate sums
uh if they are not independent it
becomes much more uh complex
uh to analyze however in practice
even if examples are related they
tend to work well except you know
the intuition to have is that if your
examples are not independent and
somewhat correlated your
one intuition to have is that your
effective data set sizes
become smaller you know what you know
think about it if you have a data set of
hundred examples
where all the hundred examples are the
copy exact copies of each other
right uh even though you know you you
have under examples they're not
independent they're all
exactly the same and your effective data
size is just one right so similarly
if if your examples are not independent
your effective data size is kind of
um is kind of reduced and and yes the
theory also does not hold in practice
you know think of it as
a smaller data set
it is much harder uh and and most of the
theories
kind of assume you have independent
observations
however when we go later in the course
for example in reinforcement learning
um they're actually you know across time
step there's clearly you know there is
dependence you know each
at each time step supposing you're
playing a game of chess what you do in
the next move
depends a lot on what you did in the
previous move they're actually not
and in those cases yes we kind of give
up the iid assumption
and you get you know different kinds of
theories there
yes question
i'm sorry
so the question is are there cases where
you can you cannot use numerical
examples
um so generally numerical solutions
always exist
um the the close form solutions may or
may not exist
that's generally the case all right
let's move on
so today the the plan for today is we're
going to cover
so um i'm going to cover the perceptron
algorithm
and ah this corresponds to section 5 in
the note
section 6 in the notes and then we will
cover
logistic regression
this is section 5
and newton's method
that's section seven
and time permitting we will um
time permitting we will we will try to
uh do a review of some ideas from
functional analysis
basically as a way to kind of prepare
ourselves for some of the future topics
there is also one section in the notes
that is
locally weighted regression that's
section four yeah we might
revisit this later but for now we're
going to just keep moving
ah right yeah so that's the plan for
today
and we'll start with the perceptron
algorithm
so the perceptron algorithm is a very
simple classification algorithm
where we are given examples
in thats r d and the correct answer or
the label or the target
now is either zero or one for each
example right something
right this this this algorithm we ah
we study it uh mostly because of
historical interest
ah and also because it's very easy to
analyze and to build some good
intuitions
right in practice um i don't know
anybody who uses perceptron algorithm in
practice
but it's it's as i said it's it's um
it's a very simple
algorithm to kind of build intuitions of
how classifying uh most
you know many classification algorithms
work right
and ah in the perceptron algorithm
the hypothesis h theta of
x ok equal to
g of theta transpose x
where g of say some variable z
is equal to 1 if
z is greater than 0 and if it is 0
if z is less than 0
right so g sum function think of it like
this
this is z
this is 0 g looks like this
g takes the value 0 until it's if the
input is
less than or equal to 0 and it is
1 you know if
yeah so and you can you can actually
define it as less than or equal to or
greater than or equal to it doesn't
matter
so let's ah let's see how it's in the
notes i think in the notes it is
greater than equal to ah anyways it
doesn't matter
let's assume it is greater than or equal
to ah which means
at at zero it is actually one
and right
um so what is happening here
the hypothesis for the perceptron
algorithm has some parameter theta
right and given a vector input
input vector x we do theta transpose x
you know just like in in the case of uh
linear regression
but the output is then
so theta transpose x can can take any
value any real value between minus
infinity and plus infinity right
it's it's just you take two vectors and
take the dot product it can be any value
whatsoever
now um we take this uh
you know real valued number and
map it to a value be you know map it to
either zero or one
right if if theta transpose x is less
than zero
we map it to zero if it is greater than
or equal to zero we map map it to one
right and
with this hypothesis the algorithm looks
something like this so
the perceptron algorithm is also called
a streaming algorithm
which means it is designed to work
in a setting where you're encountering
examples
one after another you don't have access
to all the examples up front
you're you're you're just given one
example at a time and you need to update
your model
and then wait for the next example and
then update your model and then wait for
the next example and so on
and the algorithm for training the
perceptron looks something like this
so
set your theta to be you know some
initialization
so generally it is just the 0 vector you
know that works totally fine
and for
i in uh one two
and so on you know uh just just a stream
of examples that are coming at you
you you perform theta
equals theta
plus alpha times
y i minus h theta
of x i times
x i okay what is happening here
so first we see that the update rule for
the perceptron
looks very similar to the update rule of
linear regression
right but they are not actually the same
what's different between the two
right h theta of x is different right uh
they they they look kind of
superficially similar
uh where given the hypo or
the hypothesized value or the predicted
value and the
actual value the update looks
rules look very similar but the
hypotheses are actually different
right in linear regression your
hypothesis was just
theta transpose x here it is g of theta
transpose x
right and
the there is there is theory to prove
that if your data set
is actually linearly separable then
this algorithm will find that
separation point your hypothesis will be
able to classify all the points
it's it's uh not entirely clear how this
you know
just looking at this form it may not be
entirely clear how the how this works
or why why it would even work right uh
for this let's let's
ah try to visualize this so
let's assume this to be ah you know x
one
through x d again in all these examples
um
i am assuming your ah x to include the
intercept term
right ah so assume it to be d plus one
or
in general it is fine to assume you know
x
in in d where d just includes the
intercept term and your true data was d
minus one dimension right uh we don't we
don't stress about that too much
so assume the intercept term is um is
included here
and let's assume your theta vector has
some current value so let's let's let's
um
let me use a different color let's
assume your theta vector
to be here
so lets lets call this theta of
t right your theta vector is currently
here
now its obvious looking at this
formulation that
what really matters is for a given new
value of x whether theta transpose x is
greater than zero or less than zero
right the actual value
you know actually does not matter what
really matters is whether it's just
greater than equal to zero or less than
zero because
it just gets mapped to one and zero no
matter how big how
how larger than zero it was or you know
how little ah
bigger than zero it was you know
similarly if you know if theta transpose
x is here or here it still get maps to
zero right so what what really matters
is
is the is is theta transpose x greater
than zero or less than zero which means
theta transpose x equal to zero kind of
forms uh a hyperplane
that is meant to separate your data your
uh
data points you want all the points all
the
all the points that have y equal to one
to satisfy the requirement that theta
transpose x is you know bigger than zero
for them
and and ah less than 0 for those that
have y equal to 0.
now if theta is this vector
theta transpose x is the hyperplane
that is
this hyper plane corresponds to
theta transpose x equal to zero
right and because theta is oriented this
way
all points in on this side satisfy
ah theta transpose x greater than
zero and all x's on on the other side
satisfy theta transpose x is less than
zero
is this clear is is this is this you
know it um
the idea here is that you know any x
that lies on this
this this uh line is perpendicular to
theta so theta transpose x will be equal
to zero
right ah and if you have an x over here
you know the inner product between them
is is you know it's basically less than
ninety degree so theta transposition
will be positive
if if you have an x over here you know
the angle between theta and x is more
than 90 so theta transpose x should be
negative
right and the line that is exactly
perpendicular to theta is
is like the decision boundary
is this clear ok now
another intuition that we want to we
want to have is
let us assume you have two vectors a and
b right let us see
this is some vector a right and let's
say this is some
vector b right and
a transpose b equals some value
right in this case suppose a you know in
this case a transpose b is is some value
less than zero
right and we desire let's
assume you know this was you know our
theta and this was some
x and let's say this was an x whose y
label was
plus one right we want theta transpose x
to be
to be positive right now
however theta transpose x is a negative
number because it is it is um
greater than 90 degrees and if the
desired value
of a transpose b or a dot b
is bigger than the current value of
a dot b is there a way in which we can
we can modify one of the two vectors to
make the desired value larger
how do we make theta transpose you know
a dot b
achieve a bigger value is is basically
the question so
one simple answer for that is
take the vector a right in this case
you know think of a as your theta vector
and you have a vector
x what we can do is
take a small a small amount of
x and add it to a which means at the
at the end of a
let us call this alpha times
x right so x is a vector
this is a vector now a
plus alpha times x oh
i am sorry lets call it b so alpha times
b
a plus alpha times b is this vector
right this is a
plus alpha times b
right and we notice that by adding some
amount of
b to a the angle between them got
closer right which means you can expect
a dot b
to be a dot
b plus alpha times a
will be a transpose b plus alpha times
a transpose a and a transpose a is
always positive which means this will be
greater than equal to a transpose b
right so if if we have two vectors
x and theta are a and b and we want the
dot product between them
to be bigger than what it currently is
one way to achieve it is to take one of
the vectors
and add a small amount of that vector to
the other vector
right similarly if the dot product
between
two vectors is bigger than what you
would like it to be
you can take a small amount of one of
the vectors
and subtract it from the other vector
right and you know here you just flip
the sign
and a transpose a will always be a
positive and so
a negative value of a transpose a is is
going to be negative and
that will make the the the updated
vector b smaller
so what what is that what is that mean
in
with respect to our equation update rule
what we say is suppose
y is 1 and the current value of h theta
x is also 1
right which means current according to
the current um
current parameter we are correctly
classifying
ith example then this will be 0
and you don't modify theta at all which
means if you encounter an example that's
already correctly classified don't do
anything
right 1 minus 1 is 0. similarly
if the current example is has labeled 0
and you're outputting your h theta of x
output
0 you know don't do anything so if you
encounter an example that's already been
correctly classified by your half train
model
don't do anything however if you
encounter an example
whose correct label is one but you are
outputting 0
then this will be 1 minus 0 equals 1. so
add some amount of x to theta
if you encounter an example whose true
label is 1 but we are outputting 0
then add some amount of that vector to
theta
right similarly if the correct label is
0 and we are outputting 1
which means you are making a mistake but
a mistake in the other way then
0 minus 1 is minus 1. so
subtract some amount of that vector from
the current parameter theta
right if you start your theta vector to
be 0 then what we see
is the theta vector that we end up with
is going to be some linear combination
of
sums of your
x's so everything that we have here
right this is real value
this is in rd
and this is rd
right so all of this is just a scalar
and
the the the basis vectors that we are
getting are basically just the examples
themselves so what we are doing is is
adding
small portions of our example to
construct a theta
and we add them in such a way that
if the current value of theta is is um
is mis-classifying it then we either add
or subtract
so for example um let's see so this
let's assume we
encounter you know some x
over here which is labeled 0
right so this corresponds to y equals 0
and theta transpose x is
less than 0 or theta transpose x
is going to be greater than 0 because
the angle is less than 90 degrees
which means now we are going to add
a small amount of this vector are we
going to add
now we're going to subtract because the
label is y equals 0
we're going to subtract some amount of
this vector from theta
so what does that look like so this is
the vector take a small amount of that
vector
and subtract it from theta and
theta t plus one will
so this is theta d plus one
and the decision boundary corresponding
to theta t plus one
will be this right so the example which
was classified as positive under the
blue hypothesis
you know after performing the update
rule could correctly classified as
negative
under the updated hypothesis yes
question
so why is the separating hyperplane
always orthogonal to theta
so theta is is is the um
is the current vector right and if if
you look over here
theta transpose x equal to 0 is like the
decision boundary
because n if theta transpose x is is
bigger than 0 it's considered positive
and if it's less than 0 it's considered
negative so you can think of theta
transpose x equal to 0
as as you know the the the separating
boundary
and if theta is in a particular
direction
the set of all x's that give you theta
transpose x equal to zero are all the
set of all points that are kind of
perpendicular to theta right
because if you take a dot product
between two perpendicular vectors the
dot product is 0.
does that make sense yes
so in practice you never use perceptron
algorithm
this this algorithm is hardly used in
practice however
it is very useful to analyze this
algorithm and to get some
some intuitions about about how the
update rule works because this update
rule pattern is is going to
you know come again and again
right yeah so this this is uh
this is the perceptron algorithm the
there is there is theory which says
if you're given a data set where your
the
xs according to the classes can actually
be
separated linearly separated then this
perceptron algorithm
which looks very simple will actually
find the separating hyperlink
next question
so the question is will we will we need
to revisit a few examples again
yeah so the question is you know if it
has three data points or if it has a
thousand data points does it matter
well so the so the answer there is if
you have like a very small data sets
then you may want to iterate over them a
few times
right but if you have a large enough
data set then you know generally just
making one pass
across the large data set should be
sufficient
next question
yeah so the question is um aren't there
an infinite number of
correct solutions for theta for a given
data set the answer is yes you
there are an infinite number of
solutions
and this algorithm will find one
solution some solution
any other questions yes
the solution change according to the
order of examples yes it can change
according to the order of the examples
and and and that's fine um you know
because we are generally interested in
some solution that works
this question
that's correct uh we use you know the
question is do we use one example at a
time and not all of them yes
this you know think of this as similar
to sgd you know
take one example perform an update pick
another example perform an update
cool so that's that's the perceptron
algorithm
now let us move on to logistic
regression
so the question is does the order matter
um
the theory of perceptrons tell you tells
you that if you have a large enough
data set go through it in any order and
you will find some separating uh some
solution some valid solution
um yeah so the order does not
yeah you'll get a different answer but
you'll still find some some support
why don't we use this in practice uh we
don't um
use this in practice because there are
many other algorithms that
work better and
the perceptron algorithm well
if you don't mind ask the same question
you know remember it ask the same
question after logistic regression so
that we can
draw some draw some comparisons
but the key take away from the
perceptron algorithm is this idea that
if you have two vectors and the dot
product is
smaller than what you would desire it to
be then
take a small amount of one of the
vectors and add it to the other right
and that's that will make
the dot product bigger and similarly if
the dot product is
is larger than what you would like it to
be
then take a small amount of one vector
and subtract it from the other vector
how do we determine alpha ah just the
way you determine alpha for
gradient descent right take a small
amount exactly
all right logistic regression
so to start off with logistic regression
it would not be an
understatement to say logistic
regression is the workhorse of machine
learning
it's probably one of the most commonly
used algorithms
in practice in production right uh go to
any company in silicon valley
the chances are if they have some kind
of a classification problem
it's way more likely that they're using
logistic regression compared to any
other algorithm
and and uh it's it's it's
surprisingly effective right and it
should probably be one of the first
algorithms
that you try for a classification
problem that you're trying to solve
right always start with logistic
regression more likely
than not it's just going to work pretty
well
so um in logistic regression ah the
setting is
very similar to the perceptron algorithm
we have
x s
in r d y
in zero one
right and when y i
equals one we call it a positive example
and when y i equal to 0 we call it a
negative example
right and this is a description of the
data it does not
you know it it is not a positive example
and negative example does not mean the
model is correctly classifying it or
model is negatively classifying it it's
just a it's just the way we call the
examples if if the label is
is plus one we call it a positive
example if the label is zero we call it
a negative example
right and the hypothesis
for the logistic regression is going to
look something like this
h theta of x is equal to
g of theta transpose x
right where it is again
similar to the perceptron
the perceptron's hypothesis where h
theta of x was equal to
g of theta transpose x the difference
is g in this case is defined as follows
so g of z where z is gen you know think
of z
as the value that you get after doing a
theta transpose x
g of z is defined as one over
one plus e to the minus z
right the
this function g of z which has the form
1 over 1 plus e to the minus c
is also called the logistic function
which is basically why this algorithm is
called logistic regression
and it actually looks
somewhat like the the um
the perceptron's g function
so g of z looks something like this
supposing this is z zero
this is one right so g of z looks
something like this
right so g of z
as so the limit of
g of z as z tends to minus infinity
equals zero and similarly the limit of
g of z as z tends to plus infinity
is as z tends to plus infinity g of z
tends to one
right and this line over here is
g of z equals 1 over 1 plus
e to the minus z
right now
if you if you compare this with the
ah perceptrons z in the case of
perceptron
it was exactly equal to 0 until 0
and exactly equal to 1
when z was greater than 0 you can think
of the logistic
logistic function as some kind of a soft
version of
the perceptron's
perceptron's version of of g
and now we define just
as in the case of of a linear regression
we define a likelihood function right so
let me say p of
y i equal to 1
given x i
comma theta
is equal to
h theta of
x and similarly
p of y i equals 0 given
x i theta is equal to
1 minus h theta of x
what this means is for any given x
any given example x we take the
theta vector that we have do a a dot
product
we get some z value run it through
g of z right and it is going to give you
a value between 0 and 1.
and now the claim is because it is a
value between 0 and 1
you are going to pretend that it is a
probability value because probabilities
are between 0 and 1
right so the probability of y equals 1
given x and theta is defined to be h
theta of x so supposing we have an x
whose theta transpose x is plus ten
so z is going to be plus ten
g of z is going to be something very
close to
one right similarly if you have a
some example x whose
theta transpose x is say minus 1
it's going to be here and
g of that is going to be a value that is
close to 0
right and if you have an example x
whose theta transpose x equals 0
g of 0 is
0.5 right so the
the the interpretation here is that if
the output of of h theta x
or the output of h theta x will be
closer to
one if the model thinks it is a positive
example
and it's going to be closer to zero if
the model thinks it's a negative example
right because if it thinks it's a it's a
positive example then
you expect the model to have theta
transpose x to be much bigger than zero
if it is much if theta transpose x is
much smaller than zero then
it would give it a very low probability
right and similarly the probability ah
that y equals 0 is always going to be
the
one minus of this function right ah if
this height is
p of y equals 1 given x and
p of y equals 0 q 1 x
and because it's it's a binary setting
ah it must be the case that
probability of y equals one plus
probability of y equals zero must equals
one right because we are talking about a
binary setting the sum of the two
probabilities which must always sum up
to one 1
and the height of this function is
basically the probability that the model
assigns
to that example that the label is 1.
so the
the correct way to think of logistic
regression is that it is
a probability machine it's not actually
a classifier right it's a probability
machine for any given example
it outputs a probability right and then
it is up to us
to choose some kind of a threshold and a
common threshold is 0.5
right it is up to us to choose some kind
of a threshold
and check whether the probability that
was outputted
was higher than that threshold or
smaller than that threshold and convert
it into a classifier
right so logistic regression plus some
chosen threshold will give you a
classifier logistic regression by itself
just outputs probabilities right but
it's common to just call logistic
regression as a classification algorithm
because ah
you know we just assume that the
threshold is 0.5
right so this is this is our hypothesis
now based on this based on these two
expressions
we're going to define the likelihood
function right
so instead of writing you know
a different expression for different
values of y
we will instead write it in a compact
way p of y
given x theta
is equal to
h theta of x
to the power of y times
1 minus h theta of x
to the power of one minus y
what is happening here what is happening
is
if y is equal to one that is if y is
equal to 1
the second term just becomes 0 you know
1 minus 1 is 0 anything raised to the
power of 0 is
is you know times 1. so in the cases
when y equals 1
it evaluates to this expression in the
cases when y equals to 0
it evaluates to this expression right
you think of this as
as as how how you would write if else in
a programming language and just like the
mathematical version of writing an if
else
right so if y equals equals 1 it
evaluates to this expression because
this becomes 0
if y equals 0 then you know this entire
thing is raised to power 0 and you get
this expression so
it's basically you know if else of this
is written in a compact way any
questions
yes
this is another way is the question is
is this another way to write the
indicator function yes this is another
way to
to write an indicator function but you
know in a more compact way right yeah
think of it as an indicator function
okay can you please repeat the question
so the is there a version of this
algorithm where the
uh the output of the algorithm is still
a probability
but the the labels
sure so i i if i understand the question
what you're saying is
um is there a version of this algorithm
where
we take the predicted h theta of x treat
it as a probability and sample y from it
and act based on that
you you can do that you can do that but
it's
far more common in practice where people
choose some kind of a threshold
and have a deterministic output so the
the version of the algorithm that you
describe will behave randomly
right and people don't like algorithms
that we have randomly right they want
columns to you know to to to be to be
deterministic so
yeah you can you can absolutely do you
can absolutely have
a randomized classifier where you take
the predicted probability and sample a y
from that
and and that's you know theoretically
that's perfectly fine but in practice
people just don't do that
good question right so this is this is
um
you know this this is how we define uh p
of y equals
y given x and in case of linear
regression
we came up with a p of y given x which
had a gaussian form
right in case of logistic regression you
know this is actually
a bernoulli distribution you know think
of this as a bernoulli distribution
where this is just p
and this is the the outcome
and given this we can now define
the likelihood function for your full
data set so l theta
is going to be product of
i equals 1 to n and
p of y i given
x i theta
right and we are able to break down our
full data set
into individual product of individual
examples
because of the iid assumption
right what do we do next just as before
we take the log likelihood log l
of theta which is also commonly written
as small l of theta
right and this is going to be equal to
the product changes into the sum
one to n and
so this this term is equal to this and
when you apply the logarithm to this
term
again the product breaks into sum this
product broke into
summation and this product is also going
to break into sum of two terms
it is going to be log of this term plus
log of this term
right this question
sir can you please repeat the question
so y should be multiplied by p of x
so what you're saying is should we have
p
of y given x
times p of x should we have
this as well so this will be
p of y comma x okay
so and yeah we parameterized by theta
everywhere so the question is that's
that's a very good question now why are
we considering our likelihood function
to be p
of y given x and why is it not p of y
comma x
why aren't we maximizing the joint
probability of
x and y and instead why are we
maximizing just p of y given x
right and what we will see later in the
course is that for many
algorithms we are going to maximize this
as our objective
and those algorithms will be called
generative algorithms
or generative models and
those and the the other algorithms which
only
limit themselves to the interest of y
given x will be called
discriminative algorithms
right for now um the
the intuition to have here is that uh
when you deploy this model
somebody's going to give you x right you
you're you know you don't have a choice
of deciding what x is you know x gets
thrown at you at production time
and you want to make a prediction on why
given that x
right and uh which is why you know we
are most mostly interested in p of y
given x making sure that we are able to
make making sure we're able to output a
a meaningful value of
y when x is just given to you right
that's that's the uh general algorithm
but
you know there are algorithms where we
uh do with this you know for for now
let's
let's let's just focus on discriminative
algorithms this week
but good good question
right so ah back to the log likelihood
so the summation so the log broke down
this product into summation
and it's going to break down this
product into summation
right and when we apply logarithm to the
first half
it's going to be y
i log
h theta of x i
plus one minus y
one minus y i
log one minus
h theta of x i
right this is our log likelihood
which we want to maximize because we
want to do maximum likelihood
right you can also optionally
formulate a loss function for this where
you take the negative sign of this and
you just
think of that as a cost function which
is
and then you want to minimize the cost
function which means which is exactly
the same as trying to maximize this
and
and then we
and then we apply gradient design
it is it is you know once you define a
log likelihood
of of the parameters given the data once
you are able to
uh write out it in this form then it's
just
wrote calculus you know you know just
just follow the same template
calculate the gradient start your theta
at some random initialization
and update it in some direction based on
the gradient right and you do that over
and over until you converge
it is the same algorithm once you define
the likelihood function
right so let us calculate the gradient
so in order to calculate the gradient
in order to calculate the gradient what
we
what we will do is first we will observe
that g of z
which is equal to one over one plus e to
the minus
z and in practice you know z
will be theta transpose x
the the derivative of this
is equal to so you can you can look this
up in the nodes
uh i'm just going to skip skip the steps
over here or
or nevermind let's just do it right
so how do we calculate the derivative of
this so
derivative of 1 over something is
minus 1 over the same thing squared
square right times the derivative of
this
which in this case will be is times
minus e to the minus z
right and this
is equal to 1 over 1 plus
e to the minus z times
e to the z times 1 over 1 plus
e to the minus 0
right
and over here you can add 1 and subtract
1 from the numerator
and this will be again 1 over 1 plus a
to the minus
z times
1 minus 1 plus e to the minus
z over 1 plus e to the minus
z this is equal to
z and this will be just
um
plus one minus one 1 plus z so
this will be 1 plus 1
minus 1 over 1 plus 8 minus
z ok and we see that this is actually
equal to just
g of z again times 1 minus g of c
so the derivative of of the logistic
function is equal to the logistic
function times
1 minus the logistic function
and using this
is that a question no question
right so using this let's
calculate the gradient of the log
likelihood
right so l of theta is equal to
so let's let's just look at one example
for now
with just one x and y and for you know
across all of them which is summation
over example so i'm just going to use x
and y for now
so l theta is y
log h theta of x h theta of x
is just g of theta transpose x
plus one minus y times
log one minus
g of theta transpose x right this just
the log likelihood written for one
example
right and now the gradient
of this will be
[Music]
y times 1
over j of theta transpose x
because log of something is 1 over that
times
g prime of theta transpose x
times x
plus 1 minus y
times log of this is 1
over 1 minus g of theta transpose
x times
minus 1 times g prime of
theta transpose x times x
just the chain rule any questions on
this
yes
how does taking the derivative of
so this is based on the derivative with
respect to theta
of theta transpose x is equal to x we
you know
we reviewed this in class 2 or something
matrix calculus
right and you know this is
y 1 over g of theta transpose x
and this is g of theta transpose x
times 1 minus g of theta transpose x
plus 1 minus y times
1 over 1 minus g of
theta transpose x times
minus 1 of again g prime is g
of theta transpose x times 1
minus g of theta transpose x
times x
and this you know these two cancel here
these two cancel
so what are we left with we have
y times 1 minus
g of theta transpose x
plus 1 minus y
1 minus y times minus 1
of j of theta transpose x
i think i forgot times x here so
times x times x
so x and x are the only vector value
quantities everything else before that
evaluates to a scalar
right whenever you're doing matrix
calculus always keep tracking the
dimensions
this the left hand side the gradient is
a vector and it's a vector because x is
a vector and x is a vector
everything else here evaluates to a
scalar
and so this becomes
y 1 minus j of theta transpose x
minus minus comes here
1 minus y of
g of theta transpose x
the whole thing times x
and this is just
so you have a y
minus y g
of theta transpose x minus
g of theta transpose x minus n minus
plus y g of theta transpose x
whole thing times x
and these two cancel and you are going
to get
the gradient to be equal to y minus g of
theta transpose x is just
h theta of x
times x so the gradient of theta
of the likelihood with respect to it as
this which means the update rule will
look like
theta equals theta plus
alpha times the gradient which is
y minus h theta of x
times x
right so we basically got the same
update rule as the perceptron algorithm
and the same update rule as linear
regression
where the only thing that changes is the
definition of h theta of x
right and again this is not a
coincidence you will see why it's not a
coincidence
but you know it looks very you know they
they look very similar
any questions on this yes questions
good question was there a reason why we
chose the logistic function could we
have chosen something else
right and the answer is
the logistic function is a natural
choice
that we're going to see why it's a
natural choice in the friday lecture
when we study generalized linear models
you could you can in in general choose
any other function
instead of 1 over 1 plus e to the minus
x you can choose any other function that
maps it between 0 and 1 you can define a
likelihood
ah function you know based on that
version of
g of theta take the derivatives and the
update rule might look different
right and by choosing the logistic
function to be of this particular firm
we get an update rule that looks similar
to the other update rules and we will
basically see the connection
in the next lecture
will be so the question is will we
deviate from linearity and i'm
intentionally not going to you know go
into more details i know and i'll you
know
i'd suggest you to wait
all right so this is this is logistic
regression right we got an update rule
and over here if you want to do
based on this update rule we can perform
gradient descent or stochastic gradient
descent
if it is stochastic gradient descent
then we sample one example randomly
plug in the values of that example
update our theta if it is you know a
full gradient descent then
here there is going to be a summation
across all your examples
any questions yes
so the question is here you know um are
we going to look at
all examples at once or you know one by
one like the perceptron and that's going
to depend on whether we choose to
optimize this with gradient descent or
stochastic gradient descent
right if we do gradient descent then
we're going to sum over all the examples
and if we choose to do stochastic
gradient descent then we choose one
random example at a time
calculate this you know this update rule
and update your theta and then pick
another example
update your theta based on the subject
rule and so on
yes the question is are we looking at
binary classification yes for now we're
just looking at binary classification
true or false
right and again um you know the thing to
note here
if you want to compare it to perceptron
is that in the perceptron algorithm
assuming we start theta from zero right
a vector of zeros
in the perceptron algorithm we were
basically
adding or subtracting our examples you
know small you know
fractions of our examples to
theta to to to kind of make progress
right and
each time we were multiplying it by some
amount alpha
and we were only performing this update
if we got the example wrong
in case of perceptron right but in
logistic regression what we see is that
h theta of
x is going to take some value between 0
and 1 it is going to look something like
this and it will never be exactly equal
to 1 or 0
right which means in every step
we will always take some amount of
x which is based on you know the
difference between
y and h theta of x it's that of x is
never exactly equal to zero or one it
will be some value between zero and one
right and and therefore you can think of
this as as like a soft version of
of you know the perceptron algorithm
instead of
deciding that we got this example
correct and just discarding it
you know we're going to learn from every
example but by you know some amount
depending to the degree
to which we got it right right this
question
um
yeah good question so the question is uh
at test time at validation time
we are given we calculated theta during
the training phase and we got a theta
and a test
example at test time we got a new
example x now how do we
classify it as as you know zero or one
you know classified as positive or
negative
and uh the answer there is that uh you
know first we go through the math
you know do theta transpose x run it
through the logistic function
and we're going to get a value between
zero and one
right and that's that's you know think
of that as the probability that the
model thinks
the the correct answer is zero or one
and then we're going to use
in practice we're going to use some kind
of a threshold you know it's commonly
you know 0.5 if the if if the uh
uh probability that was that was
predicted was you know greater than that
threshold which is typically 0.5 we kind
of think of that as as a positive
example
and as you know another another student
suggested some time ago uh you could
also
take the probability and sample your y
based on that probability if the
predicted output probability was like
0.99
then you know most of the times you're
going to sample y equals 0 1
y equal to one right uh and and that can
be your prediction in which case your
your model is uh is like a random model
but if you have a threshold then it's a
deterministic model
good question yes
yes
yes yes so the question is in you we can
think of in the case of perceptron
the resulting theta to be a linear
combination of just the misclassified
examples during the training phase
right whereas with logistic regression
it's going to be some linear combination
of all your
examples exactly and the the weights of
the combination is
going to depend on how correct or wrong
we got each example
during the training phase yes
yeah yes so the question is during
training phase for you know when we
encountered an example
if we got it like really wrong we
predicted a very low probability
when the correct answer was a high you
know is equal to one then you know
the difference is going to be big
exactly
right so that's that's logistic
regression and
you'll be implementing this in your in
your homework
but in your homework uh if i remember
correctly you'll be
implementing it with
newton's method
so here is another optimization
algorithm
that you may use in place of gradient
descent
right in in the case of gradient descent
we just took the
ah we just took the gradients
and adjusted our theta values according
to
the direction in which the gradient
pointed us to
instead there is another algorithm
called
newton's method
right newton's method and
think of this as
alternative to gradient descent
gradient descent or stochastic gradients
think of this as an alternative to
gradient descent
and the intuition for newton's method is
is
something like this right so
let us draw some pictures where
so let us assume we are trying to
we are trying to minimize a function
minimize some kind of a loss function
right and let us say your last function
it looks like this
and similarly for the same
setting here we are assuming
uh a one dimensional input
right um so the derivative not the
gradient the derivative
um let's call it l prime
of theta how would that look like so
until this point
the gradient is negative or the
derivative is negative so in this region
to the left of
of this minima the function will
probably look something like this
and then to the right of this point the
gradient is kind of positive
right so maybe it
kind of looks something like this
does that make sense so this is our loss
function
and this is the the
ah the first derivative of our last
function
and what we want to do is
find the point where the loss function
is is is minimum
which means find the point where
the derivative crosses 0
right does that make sense and
there is this algorithm called newton's
method
so newton's method is a way
in which for any given function you know
some f of x
it finds it's a way in which you can
find those values of x for which
f of x equals 0 right and the
those values of input for which a
function evaluates to 0
are also called like the roots of the
function right so newton's method
is a root finding method
right where for any given function f
it will it will find the input values
at which the function evaluates to zero
and what we are going to do
is apply newton's method to the first
derivative of our loss function
right and the way newton's method works
is like this
start with some random initialization
you know just like gradient design you
start with some
random initialization of of your thetas
um
let's call it this you know let's call
this theta
of 1 the random initialization
right and newton's method will
approximate
the function by a linear function
that is equal to the given function at
that point
so maybe i will use a different color
so the black line is supposed to be a
curvy line and the blue line is supposed
to be a straight line
where the the the blue line is the
linear approximation
of the of the first derivative
right and once you have a linear linear
function
finding the root is very easy right and
in newton's method what we do is
approximate a function
by ah by the linear b by its
the linear ah a linear function and
solve for the root of the linear
function
and consider this to be your theta 1
right and from this point repeat the
process
right calculate the construct a new
approximation so
i am going to mark iteration 2 with red
color
and over here the linear approximation
might look like this
and solve for
the second approximation and that's
going to be theta
2 and and so on and once you get closer
newton's method converges extremely fast
to the to the true answer right
instead yeah what did we do in gradient
design in gradient descent we started
um over here right
and the gradient pointed us in the
rightward direction and we took a small
step here
and we you know ah and we saw that the
gradient was still and we took a small
step here
and we kept taking small steps until we
reached the minimum
in newton's method what we do is we we
look at the gradient function
at the first derivative at each step
approximated by a linear function and
solve that linear function
to be equal to zero right and
jump to that point so say from theta one
we
we uh trigger it wrong so call this
theta zero
from theta zero we jump to theta 1 and
from theta 1 we jump to theta 2
and what we see is that the rate at
which
the sequence of thetas
converges to say the true theta star or
you know
let's call the state of star as the true
global minimum
the rate at which newton's method
converges is much much faster
than the rate at which regular gradient
december converge
all right and the newton's method update
rule
looks like this
this question
so yeah so the diagram was a little
small so let me let me draw a better
version of the diagram
right so i'm going to draw
let us assume this to be our
this is the first derivative right so
start
at some theta naught
right so this is the derivative
there is a corresponding you know true
loss function right this is the
derivative this is not the last function
right so at this point the function will
you know the function value some
somewhere over here right
it's a curled function instead we
approximated by a linear function
right which means
and here i am going to use a different
color um
so the blue line is the first linear
approximation
right and this
is going to be theta one right
and similarly
this is where this is ah l prime of
theta one
and construct yet another linear
approximation at the new point
in the way and the place where the
second one this will be theta two
ok does that make sense at every point
construct a linear approximation
solve for the linear approximation and
the solution is
the next next location for our theta
that's where we move to
ask this question
yes so the question is what happens if
there's a non-convex function
i'm going to come to that right
yeah and and the update rule for
newton's method is
supposing we we call this f of theta
the update rule for newton's method is
theta of t plus 1
equals theta of t
minus
f of theta over f prime of theta
right this is the update null rule for
newton's method
and now our f was the
the first derivative of our loss
function so if we plug in
our loss function here
what we get is theta of t
plus one equals theta of
t minus l prime of theta
over l double prime theta
does that make sense
yeah evaluated
so when when we find the the
new theta is there some kind of a step
size here
yeah in practice you will use a step
size
i am coming to that and
so this is newton's method but however
this was
using scalar valued inputs right in
practice however
our loss function has a vector valued
input because we have you know
theta is a vector um
and so this was for in the scalar case
a scalar theta for vector theta
the update rule looks like this
where
right so in the
in the scalar case we would divide
the first derivative by the second
derivative but in a vector case
the first derivative is going to be a
vector and the second derivative is
going to be a
the hessian matrix right and we cannot
divide
a vector by a matrix right that that's
not a meaningful operation
ah so instead what we have is this
variant of newton's method which is
called
newton-raphson method
which is a vector version of of newton's
method
to you know for vector valued inputs and
h over here is the is the hessian
and you invert the hessian that's like
you know
dividing the second taking the the
reciprocal of the second derivative so
you invert the hessian
multiply it by the gradient and that's
going to be the
the the direction in which we ah
in which we are going to head and in
practice
it is very common to have a learning
rate here as well
um though you know in in many cases you
don't need an extra learning rate so
think of this
you know compare it to gradient descent
in gradient descent it was
pretty much the same except for having a
hessian
right but in newton's method you
multiplied by the you know
multiplied by hashing as well because
essentially what what's happening by
multi multiplying it by the inverse
session is that you're you're trying to
account for the curvature of the loss
function you know that's that's that's
the intuition to have right
in in in
gradient descent you're only looking at
the direction of this
of the steepest descent ah but then the
curvature of the function can be pretty
uh unusual and newton's method kind of
accounts for the the the second level
curvature as well
and this this um func this algorithm
generally works much faster in terms of
the number of steps required to converge
but there's a catch
the catch is that
calculating the gradient is is you know
ofd in terms of the time complexity
and that is all that we need for doing
gradient descent
however the hessian is you know d by d
so you have o of d square for
calculating the hessian
and even further you need to invert the
hessian so that's about order d cube
right so if your d is high dimensional
then newton's method even though it
requires a fewer number of steps
the cost of each step can be
prohibitively high
right and and it is that trade-off that
you need to that you need to do in terms
of deciding whether you want to use
gradient descent or
newton's method right another
ah point to note is that newton's method
is a root finding method which means
if your
l prime of theta look like this
right if l prime of theta look like this
which means
your cost function l of theta
was
like this then it went up
and then it came down again
right newton's method is only is going
to find you one of the roots
right it could it could find either the
root where
the the the first derivative is going up
which means over here or it could find a
root where the first derivative was
going down
which means over here and it's going to
depend on initialization
you know did you initialize close to you
know the first
the the first stationary point or did
you size close to the second stationary
point it's
newton's method is just going to take
you to the nearest
stationary point of that function right
stationary point means
a function where the gradient is zero it
could be a minima it could be a maxima
it could be a saddle point
right newton's method is going to just
take you to the nearest stationary point
which also means that newton's method
throw a function at it it is going to
take you to the nearest stationary point
and if it is a convex function it is
automatically minimizing it
if it is a concave function it is
automatically maximizing it so it is
kind of like plug and play
right you can even flip the sign of your
function and throw it at newton's method
and it's still going to recover the same
point
it is going to take you to the nearest
stationary point it could be a maximum
or a minimum so flipping science
is not a problem right so that's
that's newton's yes question
it's going to find the nearest
stationary point
right if the nearest stationary point is
the only stationary point then it is
you know and it's a local minima then
it's the global minima
but if your if your function has lots of
local minimas or lots of local maxima
it's actually taken to the nearest
stationary point
right and and and that's the reason
newton's method is most commonly used
only with convex functions or you know
concave functions
whereas gradient descent does not have
that limitation gradient descent will
always
keep take you will take you down down
and down right if if
if the nearest stationary point is a
local maxima
gradient descent will not take you to it
the gradient descent will take you
you know only down whereas newton's
method is just going to take you to the
nearest
station yes question
yeah so the um uh for sgd so
newton's method generally does not work
well with sgd
uh and the reason is because in in you
know if if you take just a few examples
the hessian may not be invertible right
you nee you need a lot of examples to
make the hessian
invertible so newton's method generally
does not work well within an sjd kind of
setting or maybe i misunderstood your
question
no it's not analogous to std so uh the
scalar version of newton's method
is um is is analogous to having a model
where you have only one parameter that's
when you can use
this method
we take one sample at a time not one
parameter at a time
yes questions
yes so gradient descent uh can be caught
in a local minimum that's right
uh whereas with uh newton's method uh
you you get caught
in the most nearby stationary point it
could be a maxima or a minima
right and and it works really well when
your function is convex
where you know that the nearest point is
the global optimum and
that's what you wanna use yes questions
you could end up in a maximum of fuse
with gradient design was that the
question
so uh with gradient descent if you
yeah so with gradient descent if you if
you have a function that has
maximus and minimus and you started
exactly
you know at the local maxima then yes
gradient descent will not make progress
because
you know the gradient there is al
already 0 that's right okay cool so
that's newton's method and
in the last few remaining minutes
you know let's let's get some intuitions
about
about functional analysis so this is
going to be
uh for the last few minutes what we're
going to cover
is you can think of it as purely
optional in the sense they're good
they're not going to be any questions on
your homeworks or
in in your exam uh from the material
for the rest of this lecture but there
are some
you know the intuitions that you that
you that you get
uh from a function analysis point uh
standpoint can be
very useful for understanding many
algorithms
that we're going to cover later this
quarter
right so what's functional analysis so
think of this as like a
a five-minute overview of functional
analysis function analysis is like
you know an advanced mathematical topic
which you know you probably spend a year
studying but
now we are just going to look at some
some intuitions right
so you can think of functional analysis
as the study of functions
right you think of it as like you know
study of functions
functions but a more common or
or a more useful interpretation of
function analysis is think of it as
linear algebra in infinite dimensions
right so the last 10 minutes or five
minutes that you're going to spend this
is is basically you know think of it as
as
if you haven't seen this material before
think of it as you know some kind of a
mental exercise to force yourself to
think
about about vectors and functions in a
different way right
it's good to learn new things but i
think it's even better to learn new
perspectives
and you know this perspective can be
very useful when you know we study
things like gaussian processes and
kernels and so forth
right so um
so assume this is vector space r three
let us call it you know x one x two
x three as the axis and you have some
point
v right
and the claim that we are going to make
is that functions and vectors are the
same
right you know functions are think of
them as an
infinite dimensional vector
and that might sound surprising
initially because we think we think of
vectors as you know something that's
like straight and linear
right and your function can be you know
like sine x can be you know wiggly right
uh so what's what's the connection there
right so uh
one way to see the connection is
a vector think of this vector v
as a function
think of this vector v as a function
defined over the domain
where the domain is
right so the index that we are going to
that the index of the
of of the space is going to serve as the
input of the function
so ah supposing this function has you
know let's let let's see so this
function has
going to call this v1 right
and
this is v3 and similarly it has some
that is v two right just the components
of the vector right so you can think of
writing this vector as v of
one equals you know v one v of
two equals v two v of
three equals v three where you know
those are the components right
think of a vector as a function right
where the the input that you are feeding
is the axis right
and the the number of axes you have
for the space is is is basically
the domain of that function of of that
vector
right now this vector can
you can also now visualize it as
a function one two three right
so this vector lets call it a blue
vector
so v one is some value v two some value
with three some value
right so think of it as a function
whose domain is just three integers and
you know it it's its uh
values is real valued right
now if you look at
a more common you know more
x in r and let us consider a function
you know think of this as
f of x equals
x square plus 1
trying to draw the same analogy here
it's just that
for this function we have an infinite
number of
infinite number of of inputs that we can
pass for these functions we have just
three possible inputs
for this function we have an infinite
number of inputs right
and the value of the function at each
point
so pretend this is one long vector an
infinitely long vector
where the value of each coordinate is
the height of the function right
so the value of the function is is is
what you fill in that
in that vector right so a vector in
three dimension
we would write it as you know
v one v two v three
and a function similarly you can write
this function as
equal to
f of x one f of x two
right and an infinite number of them
right so a function
can be explicitly written out with you
know
by the values the function evaluates to
at different points
and its it looks very similar to a
vector right it is just
infinitely long and
this analogy is you know you got to use
some amount of imagination because here
you know we are we are this works only
for countably infinite
kind of kind of infinities but imagine
you can you know you write it to every
possible real value right it's like you
know an
uncountably infinitely long vector
right that is the kind of intuition you
want to have
now you know just the way you
you know if you have a function defined
over three elements you can map it into
a three-dimensional space
in the same way you can you can you can
map this function in
you know an infinite
dimensional space right so imagine you
have an infinite
number of axes right
imagine you have an infinite number of
axis i cannot write on the board i am
sorry
and there is a point let us call this f
such that x 1
x 2 x 3 you know and and there are you
know an infinite number of these
and the value of a function
at a given axis because
each axis corresponds to one possible
input
so the value of the of a function at a
given
input is the same as the coordinate of
the vector
at the taxes right which is which is the
same analogy
from here to here right the value of the
function
at a given input is basically the
coordinate value
of the vector along the taxes right
just extend that to an infinite infinite
dimensions
which means now you can
and having this this this functional
space
of of functions being
points in an infinite dimensional space
will be super useful for some of the
algorithms that we are going to study
and you can actually to to formalize
this a little more
or to to kind of strengthen your
intuitions some more
let's kind of draw comparisons of
different concepts
so on the one side you're going to have
finite phase yes
infinite case right the finite case you
have a vector
and generally call it v in the infinite
case you have a function
let us call it like f of t
right and in the finite case
you would have some kind of an index
right think of you know like v one v two
v three the the
the the axes uh which are which are like
uh the indexes
and they are generally you know some
kind of say one to d for example
if you have d dimensional space
and in case of the infinite case for
functions it is basically the domain
over which the function is defined
right over here it is like r
and for a vector you have components
right and in the infinite case you have
values of the function at at different
inputs
right does that make sense and vectors
are generally
represented with an explicit
representation
right so you generally write v equals
you know v one v 2 v
v d right you just write out the actual
values of
of the vector but functions generally
have
you know some kind of a symbolic
representation
which means you know you have some kind
of a shortcut you know given the index
you know what's the value
you know some kind of a rule but given
the index what the value should be
right you can you can you know just as
well think of you know
an explicit representation function
where you are just writing out
all the values of the function at every
possible input as one long vector
right is the same intuition you want to
have
and few more things so in in vectors you
have a dot product
right dot product ah where
you can write the you know between two
vectors u
and v equals sum over i
u i v i
right and similarly uh with with
functions you can actually take an inner
product between two functions
and that would look like this you know f
comma g
equal to integral of
f of t g of t
dt and then this is this is you know
perfectly valid in a product between two
functions
right it's it's just the extension of
the inner product to to uh
an infinite infinite dimensional setting
and and in fact you know
um this form you might be familiar you
know this
if f is like a probability density
function and g is like a random variable
you know expectation
of so the expectation of some
g of x where x is drawn according to
some
distribution p is actually just the
inner product between p
and g
right and you have a matrix right
matrix a
the equivalent thing over here is some
kind of a
two input function right let's let's
let's uh call it k
of s comma t where
in in a matrix a you have a i j to be
that
you know the specific element of the i
throw in j column but for
for uh in an infinite dimensional
setting just evaluate the function at
the two given
inputs right and
and so on and and you can you can um
each matrix is you can think of it as a
linear operator which means
you have linear operators on functional
spaces as well right so for example
a of x let's say y equals a of x
is a linear operation on a vector
similarly you can have a linear
operation
in functional space and one such example
is you know
f prime equals d of
f where you have a function f
and differentiation is a linear operator
right and you get an output function
right d is ah you know you can think of
differentiation as
one big you know infinite by infinite
dimensional ah dimensional matrix
right and the the ah and there are you
know
you can draw further analogies for
example you have
eigen vectors
for a matrix a such that a x
equals lambda x similarly for some kind
of
this is finite this is
infinite similarly you can have
um eigenvector eigen functions for
some operator right so if
f prime equal to
[Music]
d of f is equal to
some lambda times f then f is
an eigen function and lambda is the
eigen value
and for the differentiation you know can
you make a guess of what can be an eigen
function for differentiation
exactly so say e to the k
t where t is the variable
is equal to k times e to the k t
right so you can think of the the
exponential as like an eigen function
for the differentiation um
differentiation operator and
and the way we represent
a x ah so if if for example
u equals a v
then we write u i is equal to
summation over j a
i j v j right
this is matrix multiplication which
means now
the kind of equivalent in the
g of s is equal to
integral of let's call it some
k of s comma t
f of t dt where
you see that
so this is like a matrix multiplication
right but it's just happening in in
infinite dimensional space
and these are also called integral
transforms
right and
you might have come across many
functions of this form already
for example when
k of s comma t is equal to
e to the minus s t this becomes the
laplace transform right and if you have
k of
s comma t is equal to e to the minus i s
t
this becomes a fourier transform so you
can think of laplace transform as
fourier transforms as
as linear transformations you know
instead of um
if it were a finite dimensional it would
be like you know a matrix multiplication
in an infinite dimensional it's it's
um you know you run through some
operator
just like multiplying through a matrix
and you get you know you
the the uh index changes from t to s
which means
you know from one axis the input changes
to the other axis right
and the idea here is the
is is the the big picture that you want
to take away from from all of this
is that functions are points in an
infinite dimensional space
right and a lot of operations that you
may already be familiar with you know
all kinds of transformation like
the laplace transform fourier transforms
are all just linear operations
including differentiation are all linear
operations on
points in this infinite dimensional
space and these points we call them
functions
just the way we call vectors and as
points in a finite dimensional space
and and this this way of thinking you
know um
of thinking of functions which we
normally think of them as you know some
kind of a curve
along some axis think of them as points
in an infinite dimension space
where the coordinate along each axis is
the height of the function at that
particular input
right and and and this kind of you know
mental dexterity of switching between
these two views
can be extremely useful when we study
things like gaussian
processes or kernel methods or even
gradient boosting you know
later in the course right anyway so um
you're not going to ask any of these on
your on your homeworks or exams
but it's just a
it's a new perspective where you start
thinking of functions
as just points right not as curves or
surface just think of them as
some points that live in an infinite
dimensional abstract space
you